yeah it was insane for him his eyes
rolled yeah i already know
every twist
[Music]
okay boys and girls and everything in
between and out of the
traditional lines bro we keep it
untraditional in here
today guys we're gonna keep the episode
short and sweet
because we just
to be honest we've got [ __ ] to do we
actually have [ __ ] to do we've got [ __ ]
to do and something oh you're taking a
piss bro 45 minutes what's that i need
more you need more
say less patreon.com forward slash shits
in gigs and you're going to get more
cars you're going to get more because
sometimes your mans will just turn up
and say you got 45 today and you're just
gonna have to deal with it bro hold that
l
my mom used to make me cod she used to
just give me cod and broccoli and i'm
like big man
i hate fish i don't want you no i don't
like fish she said swear shark shut up
have you got not fish money
have you got mcdonald's money here you
got mcdonald's money you've got to take
away money go again then
fam if you're under my roof
you're having fish bro cause i like fish
so i'm gonna cook fish and you're gonna
eat the fish
so fam sometimes your boys will rock up
and say we're doing a type 45 and you're
going to have to hold the 45 unless
you've got patreon money
unless you've got hour 10 months
if you want to hold a young 90 minutes
you got 90 minute money patreon.com for
money
so it's like shits and gigs and it's
going to cost you three pound a month 10
for your day run the pizza sng guys
already know guys if you're watching on
youtube like comment subscribe chirp
sitting in those comments notification
bells on we've been dropping more and
more and more content and we can intend
to doing the same if you're listening to
us on any audio and listening device app
whatever please give us a nice review
we've got a few thousand in the bag now
and most of them are five star i'm just
throwing it out there if you want to
keep that train going and actually be
part of the team part of the cult and we
we if you if you're on patreon you
already know we're promoting captains
now
we've got a leadership
hierarchy and with the white robes and
yeezys coblemon might have a gold trim
hey you could be there as well yeah you
could be there that could be you
obviously your man's will be here yeah
and i'm gonna have a fair
hat on
um
yeah but everything under that yeah it's
up for grabs so guys um
make sure you're truly truly part of the
cult tell a friend to tell a friend and
leave some nice reviews and without any
further ado we need to get straight into
some laughs because we're on a limited
time frame with you guys today a type 45
so fuja is going to go straight into the
backbone of twitter
find us satin funny to giggle at feel
good about
bring us back from our horrible what day
is it it's [ __ ] monday so it's yeah
everyone hates monday everyone here give
us a reason not to hate monday's tweets
that's what we're trying to say all
right guys
some
lovely people sent me over a twitter
thread
and i just have to read it out all right
say less what's the
the question was
what's the horniest thing you ever did
the horniest thing you ever did was the
horniest thing you ever did right okay
cool
smell my friend's sister's underwear
jacked off to her handwriting
what
jacked off to her handwriting
that's sucked my own tool to stop my own
tool thinking about her
first of all impossible
second of all raw
fingered my ass pronounced it was hers
[Laughter]
oh he definitely was hoping his
pretending is her ass
wow
how could you
right
suppose
how could you that have that much
presence of mind yeah that you ignore
the penetrative nature
and focus on the finger sensation
the nerves aren't adding up
because i i'd only be thinking about the
violation oh fam because
you're not comfortable regardless yeah
because the angle you have to do it
regardless it's like
yeah your mental state is going to be
there yeah right it's it's it's weird
it's pretty it was hers backwards wow
bro
i rubbed my dick with my legs while
taking my sats and not admit exact
sweater just this what are that ones
question hit me honesty truth time okay
have you ever have you ever known from
like a dry hump situation
i would probably say i pre-calmed when i
was younger but i definitely haven't
night i've noted have you like a full-on
like
like a actual nut from what from from
this from no no not from that from like
um
there was a woman there
this was this is a guy that's again
that's what i meant that's what i meant
that's what i'm saying
not from self-pleasure no not from
self-thing from a girl yeah yeah yeah i
was really fam
i was virgin
i'd barely touched girls at this point
had one thing around the yard no one was
home
she was
adamant there was never going to be sex
adam and that just made it so much worse
and i was like
16 15 16. okay
horny
so the lipsons were lips in and the dry
humping was dry humping fam and she was
saying all the right stuff like say i'm
banging her
[ __ ] making all the right noises saying
all the the right taunts
you [ __ ] and then yeah
so fam after and we were going for time
yeah so once we'd been going for
literally like a strong half an hour of
it
my tool physically couldn't handle it
anymore
so i had to like lock it in yeah and be
like i'm in pleasure town bro like i'm
my tool will explode if i don't know the
blue balls are so agonizing
that my body would like fan would you
can't do this to us i was wearing uh
if you if you can remember
i was probably wearing trackies because
it was after school okay i remember it's
after school yeah yeah so i changed out
my school uniform but she was still in
her uniform
yeah she was still in her uniform and i
changed that in my uniform so i remember
i was probably wearing shorts or
trackies shorts you're pissed
shorts you're pissed you're probably
i remember
this that hasn't happened to me before
but i think i've said it on the pod
before as well i remember when i was a
youth i was a blosky little you horny
horny i think i just discovered
um the porn on sky like 996 and all them
channels oh what's it called redness and
red hot hot and damn things there
just discovered all of that that's oh
just discovered they used to have one
with secretary of glasses he used to
send me bizarrely
yes
yes i remember her
when he used to send me lupin i remember
her
yes
[Music]
so
i had gone to bed now and this is back
in the days when me and my sister were
sharing a room but as i said that was a
blasty little
separate beds but share the same room
so i was in my bed now
but i was
i was rock solid
and i was wearing one of those i was
wearing those boxes where they had the
the little button oh i think you're
tommy's story before yeah
yeah oh god yeah my dick went through it
just it just made its way on its way
through and
all i know is i was in bed i was
gyrating brother i was gyrating and you
know do you know the maddest thing it
felt so good but i didn't even know what
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i couldn't even knew what [ __ ]
i was in there bro
i don't think you did your dna kick took
over i was
in there
i was like what
fam i knotted
i stopped i
knocked oh god my abs are killing me so
that's the horn yourself oh bro
i was in there
me and my bed
[Music]
there was no one there bro
oh i've been there fam it was
unbelievable oh bro i'm unbelievable the
first time i ever nutted
i was
so breathtakingly horny bro
breathtaking like i couldn't focus i
couldn't see like as nothing but hard
dick it was like
either my tool to touch was like piping
like ah like
it was literally screaming like james do
something
yeah cool me down
help me down literally help me and i'm
like bro i don't know what to do that's
hilarious and then yeah oh bro i
remember i tried to fap yeah and this is
i didn't know it was a thing or whatever
tried to fat and then got locked in into
the imaginary
pum
and wow
but it didn't even feel good oh because
i've never felt anything like it so my
tool was just doing this throbbing
throbbing thing and i was like i broke
it i broke it i broke it i broke it okay
but it didn't my my brain didn't know
how to compute that this is good yeah so
and nothing even came out okay my tools
was going boom boom boom boom boom boom
i'm like oh whoa whoa whoa and it
wouldn't stop bro
because nothing's coming out
because nothing's come out my tools
still going bang bang bang and i'm like
oh [ __ ] like i'm so scared and because
you know like it doesn't feel like
anything you've been fell before so i'm
like i can't even it's so
alien i can't even tell if it feels good
because i'm just scared
oh bro that went on for like 30 seconds
that's hilarious the scariest 30 seconds
of my life oh scared 30 seconds of my
life and then my tool just like went
down simmered down i was like [ __ ] that
was scary didn't rank again for weeks
until we got into that same situation
again and my tool was like bro
you need to and then yeah
not eddie
stole my auntie's pants
so i can smell them and i still have
them to this day someone replied to that
collected strands of his hair left on
the hoodie and made up made out with it
with a voodoo doll that i created
no that's impossible
well what kind of obsessiveness are we
talking about here it's not even
wow i'm never gonna read that one okay
i'm actually not even gonna read that
okay
she's squeezed into a tissue than i used
it to jack off
no bro
where did you get the tissue from the
bin
oh my god
i know a dude who admitted to jerking
off to 50 shades of grey the book not
the movie
that's
imagination that's the imagination he
locked in bro
you know when people obviously you know
you know in like uh like kuroko in a
basket yeah any man in the zone zone
zone do you know what kind of zone you
need to be into lock in
the 50 shades of grey wank from a book
nah brother that's
that's
yeah
that's just
boxes
swing leather oh my god [ __ ] hell
oh pause
um
oh jesus this is so funny
um i will do you oh what was it
if you i think actually i was with you
the other day
um i was talking about this so you were
talking about um like male porn stars
and stuff okay and i keep hearing i'm
interested to see what the comments say
about this now i keep hearing chats
about this brother uh i said his name to
you
um
on the day it was uh owing great owen
gray
owen gray to me i didn't send it to you
said it i said it to you um
we were with jay as well
we're talking about male porn stars or
something
and then i mentioned that yes love this
brother called great yes yes
yeah and like he's just weird looking
bro okay but um
apparently this dude can
[ __ ] i swear he can't [ __ ] i'll swear
and i think it's on a passionate thing
oh okay so i messaged one of our friends
a female friend and was like oh what go
on what are your thoughts on owen gray
expecting her like pre-eyes this this
dribble emoji
she said who's that i said ah pornstar
apparently yes love him
she sent me a picture and was like
desperate and it was him
legs behind his head
i get
pegged
and i was like
oh no no no no
oh my god
oh my god no no she was like is this
what you're into
no no no no
no raw oh okay
just forget this whole thing ever
happened bro humiliating oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that he was spread out nah
i was like oh [ __ ] i wonder if you guys
love him yeah they like to take control
over him
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
i kept the used condom and chewed on it
later
no you didn't bro
who's this horny fan
who
is this horny
i've done some stuff when i'm horny bro
but this is wild
this is wild
wild
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
only had one pair of socks by night in
them and went to school
[Laughter]
oh my god that's hilarious
that's disgusting
some crusty soggy socks
yuck i had the max amount of pawn tabs
open on my phone in brackets 500. now
between mike now between my computer and
my phone it's about 700 pawn tabs
that's a condition that is a serious
that's a condition
that's not even the most horny you've
been that's like a chronic condition
see someone asap
i used i asked her what her perfume was
then i bought it and used it as a lotion
to beat my meat
no
crazy
that's a crazy
amount of horniness like default someone
should
be that horn yeah you went to the shop
with this motive
you went to the shop with this intent
this is this is past horny
spraying his hand
to fap possibly gonna sting in front
yes it is for one yes it is
just to get that ambiance that aura of
sweat and perfume and nah he wanted her
aroma and he said what
yeah what's your perfume what's that he
spent money on this invested in this he
just mixed a bit of perfume with some
body cream yeah 100 he he creamed and
sprayed it
that way
yeah that would have been moist
yeah it was insane for him his eyes
rolled yeah i already know
every twist
yeah hundred percent oh my god
he took his own song yeah yeah yeah he
probably like twisted his nipples and
everything he needed to be in there
[ __ ] out no people shouldn't be that
horny yeah that's it for that segment
wow that was a little interesting that's
scary bro that's scary oh
people are crazy okay guys real quick
gonna take a little break
real quick guys we're going to take a
little break to pay some bills and keep
the lights on guys and you know what
time it is it's time to throw some love
at our boys and girls over at manscape
guys so real quick quick question
do you guys intend on wearing sandals
this summer bro
shark the answer's probably yes
wearing sandals with some nasty toenails
come on fab let's not let's not do it
let's not do that city boys are up let's
stay up let's stay all the way up fam so
what you need to do guys is take a look
at the shears 2.0 a luxury a luxury nail
grooming kit this kit includes stainless
steel nail cutters tweezers and grooming
scissors bro with the performance
package your balls will be ready to
impress but make sure you cover the rest
bro with shears 2.0 guys along with
everything else that you already know
comes with the performance package
what you need to do
is head on over to manscaped.com
the code is s
n
g sierra november golf
manscape.com
sierra november golf
20 off
free shipping across the globe guys
jump in today it's summer city boys are
up smooth sack summer's slapping
get in there get swimwear and uh clap
cheeks as always guys get back to the
episode thank you thank you thank you
all right you've got trash news for us
tonight yes i do have a trash news for
you guys right so i saw this tweet and
it's ah it it frustrated me even though
i don't really care
but emmerdale you know all right
teacher teacher is going viral after
quitting his job to become a manager at
walmart because it pays 12k more than
being an actual teacher
he will be making 55 grand at walmart
and as a teacher he was only making 43
grand not even using his degree
this is american right obviously yeah
yeah yeah
40k is a lot for a teacher um
you get paid more to be a walmart
manager 55 bags
man said yeah i'm leaving education
right so right
that's fascinating to me because i have
so many like um
obviously teachers aren't to blame for
this of course but like um
i have so many
like issues kind of with like education
as a whole okay in terms of like
it's
i just
from my very nuance like on
no pun intended uneducated opinion and
viewpoint it's very like
for one old school
and for two
just like lazy
in terms of like
the way like education intentionally
doesn't keep obviously i understand like
doing a national curriculum yeah is
[ __ ] hard yeah yeah yeah but like
do you remember like i was thinking
about even when we were kids okay do you
remember being in exams and there's like
you're not allowed to use a calculator
yeah
and it's like why and the teacher's
answer was well there's gonna be times
in your life where you're not gonna have
a calculator and i'm like no there isn't
there really isn't there will never be
an occasion but i will need to know any
mathematics without a calculator facts
fact it's not gonna happen not
physically impossible all i need to know
is what to put in the calculator that's
like the hard part like in terms of like
yeah like
the algorithm that you need to put in
there to get the answer yeah
understanding the the fundamentals of
how the maths go together that's all in
here that's all in here that's what you
should be teaching me
but the actual sums yeah calculator let
me type it in calculator and on top of
that now is like
we're never
touch wood
further than that
we're never not gonna have google
google's gonna be a thing forever yeah
so what are we doing yeah like there's
just so like
six hours a day every day and i'm pretty
sure it's mandatory now to be in school
to 18.
when we were there you could leave at 16
and do an apprenticeship and all these
things yeah they don't do anything
anymore you have to stay in like
actual education before so basically you
have to do college you have to do
college um
yeah you have to you can't just go get a
job you have to do it oh mad you have to
do something
even if like it's even if it's the same
course as what your apprenticeship would
be or whatever okay you have to stay in
um
would you call it compulsory education
until you're 18. okay um
and it's like
google's never not going to be a thing
yeah it's never not going to be a thing
so like at what point is the
order this gonna change
to what like what
when is the main when is the focus going
to be on like critical thinking
and like
problem solving
and just like understanding how the
world works and like maybe get to a
point now where maybe like
business is like an actual thing that
people should be talking about like they
don't teach business they have business
studies of course and you can do
business degrees but just like
no one no one understands tax yeah until
you're a full-fledged adult
and only you only then understand it if
you get self-employed yeah you learn on
the job no one teaches you literally no
one teaches you right and it's like why
like instead then when i'm doing psag
for what i'm doing textiles for what
reason
dt fam woodworking emptying there for
what reason yeah education is very not
necessarily backwards but it's so out of
date it's really
out of there really out of date
and i don't even know how they would
change it that's the thing that's what
i'm saying yeah changing a national
curriculum is a serious thing but it's
like it's time
it was time time ago back a day it was
time it was time when we were still in
school it was time to change it and now
it's definitely time to change it's
taken over everything like there needs
to be a different change as to what
needs to be learned in school like we
don't not everyone needs maths english
science this did you know i mean nothing
needs all
12 or 13 subjects you learned in
secondary school yeah like i genuinely
believe just like like i said
caveat i don't know what i'm talking
about but
from my like very
blurry perspective yeah it's like the
way i would want my kids to like
understand
stuff is like
um
maths like understanding how to use
maths like even if you're using a
calculator understand how to use math
understand mathematics
and unjust have like
really good
uh reading skills really good spoken
like english vocabulary yeah yeah really
good writing really good vocabulary
and
literally just like
be a [ __ ] google whiz and like learn
coding and [ __ ] like that and like um
just yeah just like
weird um
i don't know like like literally like
critical thinking like opinion versus
like debating and all these things like
the good because
because of like google yeah
you no longer need to learn
so much [ __ ] about so much
geography irrelevant who gives a [ __ ]
about history irrelevant yeah get rid of
it now we've got so much time textiles
[ __ ] off dt [ __ ] off we don't need to do
these things unless they actually choose
that they want to do it and then like it
could be it's going to be a massive
massive massive massive massive massive
massive massive change but like it's so
necessary it's so essential like it has
to be done
in order to like progress [ __ ]
humanity and speaking of we were
speaking the other episode about like uh
or was it this one like andrew tate last
episode yeah when we were speaking about
andrew tate before
um
he said something the other day that was
i was listening to and he was like
he was basically cussing school and
saying how school was [ __ ] and he was
saying everyone knows school [ __ ]
without saying it of course because all
you have to do
is
see someone pull up in a ferrari
and he's basically said no one has ever
said the sentence like no one's ever
pulled up in the ferrari and no one has
ever ever said the sentence and thought
ra i bet he did really well in school
that sentence doesn't exist it's never
been spoken yeah yeah yeah you see rich
people you don't think they did well in
school
that's it
they've done something else they've done
something else yeah and like um
yeah man i just feel like
there's so much stuff i've learned as an
adult yeah you'd be like bro
we could have scrapped bare stuff after
school so anyway to get back to the
point that we were making about the guy
[ __ ] having to quit being a teacher
to be like that it's like
this is
reinforced
by
teacher salaries
because
even the government in terms of where
these budgets are going yeah
the government doesn't value education
yeah
which means the teachers are underpaid
yeah they see it as less of a priority
then it's babysitting yeah it's
literally babysitting
that's all it is it's just [ __ ]
babysitting
because kids learn more on youtube yeah
[ __ ]
way more
way more they need to they need to just
start doing a situation where when you
reach a certain age ask the kid what are
you [ __ ] interested in yeah not even
what do you want yeah we're not even
interested in it yeah yeah then we can
go from there
we can definitely go from there because
there'll be branches of things that can
be taught or can be
you know
they can open their eyes to and then
they can follow that path as opposed to
doing eight subjects every single day
for five days a week for ten years do
you know what i mean it's like i'm going
to be drained i'm not even going to be
wanting to go to school i go to school
for bands i don't go to school for
education that's what yeah bro and like
if you think about like
all the people who like
all the people who um
like what you call it
who like you look up to like the
high-class intellectuals and stuff like
that it's just like
they're really good at certain [ __ ] and
they're really good at just like
[ __ ] having discussions and
articulating themselves and just like
imagine having like a whole section of
education that was down to that was
solely um based on that communication
yeah like how can humans communicate
with one another how we get our points
across how we articulate ourselves the
importance of vocabulary the importance
of intent the importance of language the
importance of critical thinking the
importance of empathy the importance of
like
understanding different cultures and not
just like [ __ ]
re was so pointless because all they
said is this person believes this and
this person believes this and this is
this and they like the quran and these
read the bible and all this stuff when
they could have been like this is like
islam this is what these men believe
this is this and this and this and like
actually get
deep into it and you're like ra
and you're like and this is why wars
start like this is like they've got so
much opportunity to like actually take
in like if we're gonna do history yeah
let's do history bro
let's do history yeah yeah let's get
into it right there like
is it and you'll be like this this is
why you can understand why when you go
to [ __ ] dubai you can get arrested
for such a minor little thing because it
all
backlogs down into all these things and
like you can understand like so many
different points of view
and just understand everything and
you'll be like ra i can actually see
why these men think like this
like that could be your education
growing up in life as opposed to just
like
[ __ ] i don't even know bro just the
boring stuff that you learned yeah just
like the [ __ ] world war two world war
ii in school is so boring it's such a
fascinating topic as a whole but the way
it was so
boring history alone was don't one of
the main things i remember from history
is um henry viii everyone remembers
henry and he's hoes
and he's hosed
what was it married divorced died
married divorced yeah yeah yeah yeah
killed me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so yeah six wives and berlin and all
demanded that's that's all i remember
henry yeah bro it was so boring and like
i said it's impossibly difficult i don't
even know how one would begin
to
reshape a curriculum
to meet 22 2022 standards but like the
further it goes on the longer it goes on
like this
the less people are going to be
interested
in
like
yeah literally the longer it goes on
like this
the less respect education will get the
less paid teachers will get the less
people will want to be teachers and
people will just end up
falling into being a teacher it's going
to be an online thing soon in like the
next 20 30 years education will be is
going to be online bro i'm i guarantee
like the main thing about education
right now is it's just like a
babysitting thing
because parents have to go out and work
yeah it is literally just that the
guardians we said before you said it
before you are a guardian yes it's a
guardian thing we don't care what you
tell them just [ __ ]
keep them for six hours for every day
bro every day mondays and friday keep
them because i've got [ __ ] to do busy
because the stuff that like yeah the
education stuff like that and there's
like
no one has any reason with like the way
the world works and stuff like that and
the way thing people learn and the way
people experience life now in comparison
to when like these kind of curriculums
were like written yeah it's so different
that why would anyone even want to
become a teacher yeah because like
there's no like oh i'm like bringing up
the youth and like all this not really
because you're teaching them boring [ __ ]
that's irrelevant today it's so
irrelevant today
um
but that's [ __ ] grim that is grim bro
i read i was like
jesus
how is that how is that okay yeah how is
that genuinely okay like fair play to
warm up like i'm not knocking out
whatever i'm not knocking any teachers
either but
that's backwards oh bro
you're paying
the people that are educating the future
generation less than people
who work in a supermarket
yeah
and that's considered a [ __ ] job do you
know what i mean yeah it doesn't make
sense bro
pride in being teachers yeah yeah and
again stupid ass pay it's like it's such
a worldwide thing it make it doesn't
make sense why educators don't get paid
what they deserve to be paid same with
people like nurses and doctors and all
those things it's baffling to me
yeah
entry-level stuff like obviously if
you're top top tier top it's different
money but entry level
big man you you
speak to more people than probably the
people at the top when you're on entry
level oh yeah right it's mad
it's bonkers anyway i've got no money
[ __ ] hit me bro okay bet this one was
wonkers to me right check this one out
yeah yeah so yesterday yeah i was
waiting for an uber in the city
the app said that my driver wasn't one
minute away in a red outlander i think
this person's australian by the way
outlander okay or american
yeah a red outlander pulls up that same
moment and winds down the passenger
window
um said hey man are you the uber
i'm reply i'm not but i can take you
somewhere
disclaimer
i'm not out here getting in random dudes
cars yeah but i had a gut feeling so i
jumped on in and cancelled my uber
bro a gut feeling fam
the banter kicked off immediately
he was going in a similar direction and
we laughed on the freeway um
we laughed on the free that it was
technically a speed date
okay okay so after 20 minutes in the car
i'm dropped off safely at the dentist he
notices we're early so we could stay
chatting if i liked i loved that he
tells me he's just bought another car a
land cruiser
and i said oh [ __ ] they're good cars i
drove one up north last year with a gal
pal
a red 60 series he said you're kidding
he pulls up a photo and it was my car
which i had sold when i returned from
said trip
he'd even keep kept the roof racks i
spent a lot i spent a lot on to get
installed
i then opened the photos of me driving
it
and clicked on one from the 3rd of
august 2021 the same date that we are
now sitting in a dentist car park as
strangers a year
later
what the [ __ ] bro
we exchanged numbers and the sexual
chemistry was almost unbearable
today comes around and i'm kicking it at
home when he bails me
it says are you home
20 minutes later we're enjoying my view
smoking and kicking back
he said you're going to give me the tour
blah blah blah they banged yeah she's
using some stupid language they banged
yeah um
after we're doing the catchy breath
thing
i asked how he was feeling yeah man said
i feel like my girlfriend might kill me
oh
bollywood twist
bollywood twist
i feel like my girlfriend might kill me
that's the post not clarity yeah
what alright i was not expecting any of
that bollywood twist wow
[Music]
awesome
that end of story
also
that's dexter you met
and how you're not understanding
how you're not understanding that
homeboys are stalkers
store there's
that's too much of a coincidence he's
coincidentally
driving past you as you're waiting for
an uber same car
same car same color and just
coincidentally offers you a
quote-unquote stranger a lift to
wherever you're going
he just happened to roll down his window
to you
randomly when he's not your uber roll
down his window
for you to say are you my uber and he
said now but i can take you somewhere
with confidence you then allow him to
take you there and whilst on the journey
he tells you
that he's coincidentally just
bought the car that you used to own
the exact same car
and you don't think these are weird
little coincidences these are red flags
these are red
deep red blood red flags what's their
what's them um yeah that dude with 12
things yeah what's that thing called you
know what i'm talking about the [ __ ]
rhythmic gymnastics
there's a ribbon thing that spirals
around yeah yeah fam that's what that's
what i mean
you're engulfed in that yeah yeah
there's a tornado around your head wow
that is a dexter thing he stalked your
whole existence and then [ __ ] you
bro and then his conscience came back oh
all of that fell through the cracks when
he said when he knighted and said wrong
what am i doing here that should have
been in the first thread yeah
most horny i've ever been
i stalked a girl bought the same car as
her so we could have crazy coincidences
picked her up randomly on a trip to the
dentist worked my way into banging her
managed to bang her i thought [ __ ]
i need to go home i've got a wife that
loves me
bro he he must have been stalking her
for the longest oh it doesn't make sense
for the lord it doesn't matter one of
them ones where
he's probably thought to himself
regardless of what where life may take
me i have to bang this game yeah you
know what i'm saying regardless of yeah
he's a man on a mission i am [ __ ] you
yeah yeah yeah if he applied this into
his like business endeavors he'd be a
billionaire booming yeah yeah booming
yeah if he put this focus into something
money related he'd be rich as [ __ ]
that's hilarious um but anyway [ __ ]
hell let's wrap up this short and sweet
with uh our ig questions yeah today i'm
gonna bang through these um i hate when
you do hang through these i hate when
you do this
what's the crit so the question of this
week is guys what's the craziest thing
you've done for money as per usual you
already know juicy
ate an apple with my hands tied behind
my back as a kid but i had no front
teeth
lied about a family death to raise money
for the funeral
wrong
i didn't do it but i was going to marry
her and off her dad for the shared
inheritance
i didn't do it but because that's yeah
you did do it
you did do it
makes uh
oh sorry makes uh made a photo shoot
with a stranger from craigslist uni was
peak times
sucks dick i'm bi unbeknownst to my
victim grips his soul and he's two
dollars i'm now a tier two patron oh my
god
raw sold my used knickers i soaked them
in tuna juice to make them extra smelly
[Laughter]
oh my god stole money from the escort my
bus employed for a week
what stole money from the escort my boss
employed for a week
raw
dynamics yeah dynamics i'm so confused
it's dynamic
yeah it's a lot raw jumped off the
brighton pier for a dare [ __ ] that no
no no no that's the most insane one i've
heard [ __ ] that
song my brother's nintendo wii behind
his back
made a video of me sitting on the toilet
having a [ __ ] for off he wanted to hear
the plops
[ __ ]
robbed my own room in the army barracks
claimed it all back on insurance
wow
went round this old guy's house to watch
porn he paid me 60 pounds i'm not gay
i'm just broke
he just went round there to watch porn
with some old brother
oh god i ate a daddy longlegs that
landed on the barbecue no
no no no no no no no no i would rather
suck dick i would literally rather suck
dick than eat a daddy long legs
nah bro he would rather suck too yeah
wow i would yammed the long legs i would
jam it home
i would that makes me feel sick i saw a
fat one the other day really i took two
steps back no no no no no no no no
i saw a fat
bro speaking of quickly i was in my yard
the other day
uh
patio doors open yeah and i swear to god
i'm watching tv and i hear this on the
window
no you never i promise you i promise you
i promise you no you are mothers i did
no you never
and then i hear this on the walls
i look
moth
dense muscular [ __ ] moth
with army colors on
i
screamed
screamed and ran out of the living room
i've never been so scared if you hadn't
said
bro
solid knot oh my goodness this thing had
weight on it oh yeah i can imagine see
the only way i got him out was because
he got caught behind the curtain back oh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i went to court and
just started
[ __ ]
and i was too scared to look for hours
terrified me bro [ __ ] it oh that's
hilarious um i keep banging for you all
right go go go go go i got paid 150 to
get taser twice by my ex's mate
but my ex is mate
[Laughter]
[ __ ] sold my dirty knickers to my
ex-husband for five hundred dollars he's
remarried and said hers doesn't smell as
good as mine oh wow
stole a junkies meth i reached into the
pocket of her bag and got pricked by a
needle don't worry i'm okay
don't worry i'm okay
no
pretending to be homeless to get a
dollar so i can get on the bus
no bro come on man
stole weed from my drug dealer um sorry
stole weed from my drug dealer's brother
and mother chopped it up with parsley
and sold it to the rich white kids that
wanted to be heard
nah fam i don't even believe that one
the rich white kids that wanted to be
heard that's a
screenplay
that's a screenplay that's every black
movie i've ever seen a snowfall yeah
signed up for a sugar baby website but
it was a scam i ended up owning the bank
twelve hundred dollars oh my god
oh dread sold my morning urine
yuck that would have been
dense
dense and polluted yuck
there's minerals in there gone off
minerals looted james
wow
my ex took my engagement ring off whilst
while she thought i was sleeping and
pawned it
she was awake
she was awake just watching man take it
off
[Laughter]
oh god whilst this guy was sleeping i
took a pic of his bank card and went
shopping online he never found out
piss take
my friend
sorry a friend of mine
a friend of mine ate cat food for four
cans of stella
no bro
these white men they do anything they do
anything for a beer
anything for a quick can
[ __ ]
this one guy sent me 30 pounds for him
to send me a picture of himself wearing
a thong
what i'm gonna read that again yeah
please do i'm a slow down this one guy
sent me 30 pounds for him to send me a
picture of himself wearing a thong can i
send you a picture of me wearing a thong
no here's 30 pounds yeah
no
i'll give you 30 pounds okay
here's the picture
cool
nuts wow
a friend of a friend offered me seven
hundred and fifty dollars to bang him we
meet weekly now when no one knows
[Applause]
i ate part of a coke can
that's a death sentence
that's a death sentence a joker [ __ ]
that sounds like what's that um called
where you put someone's mouth stomping
that's one of them ones eight parts of a
coke can no you didn't bro aluminium big
mounting see someone
sly stop that
i don't think you understand what i'm
feeding right now
this is a funny [ __ ] boy
i ate bugs any bugs they wanted for the
right prices
oh my god that's one of the funniest
ones you've ever read
yo
you
[Laughter]
any [ __ ] they wanted for the right
price
[ __ ]
[ __ ] oh
that was unbelievably funny
i've got a few more all right go go go
go go stole 100 pounds from my man
whilst it was taking a [ __ ] oh god
threw up in a container and sold it to a
guy who likes black vomit for 400 pounds
but that is what
[Laughter]
oh my god put ice put ice up my butt and
sat on his face so he could drink it as
it melted my rent was due
i've been taking sneaky pics of girls
feet and selling them on only fans under
a different name no way dated this dead
thing just cause he dropped racks on me
my boy's still bullying me till this day
[ __ ] sake i let a gang watch me crack
and suck the marrow out of a chicken
bone oh
dear
last one
i told my grandma i was pregnant so
she'd give me the abortion money i had
bills to pay
oh my god
wow
that's emotional torment
fam the bugs and the black vomit
that's the funniest thing i've ever
heard in my life
wow bro maybe bug for the right price
[ __ ]
yo
oh that murked me that was way funnier i
thought it was going to be
oh god jesus all right guys
uh apologies for the shortness of the
episode today like i said we've got [ __ ]
to do so come and see us uh on thursday
yeah promise it's gonna be longer yeah
patreon.com forza ships and gigs where
you'll get your giggles out
um and as always guys we love you like a
fat kid loves cakes
let's go bless
[Music]